pour lutter contre le vol des engins et
accessoires donc il convient notamment
de ne pas laisser les clés sur le
contact du véhicule de ne pas non plus
laissé dans l'habitacle de bloquer le
volant avec un antivol mécanique des
conseils qui paraissent logiques mais
encore trop peu appliquées au quotidien
rené est là pour prévenir la délinquance
en analysant les situations à risque
aujourd'hui rendez vous à la ferme de
coubertin de saint rémy les chevreuse on
a eu un gros événement ici c'est un
incendie et donc suite à cet incendie
je les ai conseillé pour mieux sécuriser
pour mieux mettre en sûreté
leur exploitation agricole donc aussi
bien la partie bâtimentaire de véhicules
que effectivement la partie commerce
un incendie à l'été 2016 après un bilan
global le référent sûreté à proposer
différentes solutions aux agriculteurs
l'exploitation a donc débuté la
construction d'un mur de séparation
nous avons effectivement travaillé avec
le propriétaire des lieux pour que le
hangar ne soit pas coller à l'habitation
et pour qui une séparation visuelle
entre le matériel à spa ce matériel des
engins et le fourrage mais quelques
points sont toujours à améliorer
c'est avec isabelle caut exploitante de
la ferme que le gendarme poursuit sa
visite il conseille de mettre les anges
en sensible plus en retrait pour fois
fort et juste repenser peut-être
réorganise effectivement le reboucher
oui voilà les mots là parce que des fois
la perte du temps de soir on va éviter
effectivement peut-être le vol de la
nuit éclairage et détection de
mouvements à proximité des zones
sensibles panneaux dissuasifs et
construction du mur et des assurances et
du département la ferme a investi entre
vingt et vingt-cinq mille euros pour sa
sécurité
suite aux conseils du référent
régulièrement ils viennent nous voir de
toute façon il passe
ils passent dans la boutique où il passe
voir mon frère qui est plus dans
l'exploitation on a des très bons
contacts avec eux pour justement nous
protéger au maximum et protéger toutes
les personnes qui viennent sur
l'exploitation la prévention en milieu
agricole de manière générale soit
différent type de vol les vols d'animaux
l'an dernier dans le département dix
mille personnes particuliers entreprises
ont été sensibilisés par ce service
actuellement les yvelines compte deux
référents sûreté un troisième est en
formation